I'm honored to enter
doc
director of the National Institute of
aging or niña at the National Institutes
of Health the niña is the principal
federal funding agency for studies of
the basic clinical epidemiologic and
social aspects of aging including the
pepper center program dr. Otis has been
director of the niña since 1993 and he
informed us today he's the second long
longest-standing director of an NIH
Center dr. ho toises visit to Yale
represents a coming of home of sorts
since he received his bachelor degrees
here in 1965 before heading up north to
Boston for his medical training at a
school not to be named dr. Otis is a
diplomat of the American Board of
Internal Medicine in 1995 he was elected
as a member of the Dana alliance for
brain initiative in 1997 he was elected
as the fellow of the American
Association for the Advancement of
science in 1999 he was elected to
membership in the Institute of Medicine
of the National Academy of Sciences as
author of more than 250 research papers
he's an influential scientist in and
contributor to the field of immunology
and he's been an outstanding and
tireless leader of the niña tomorrow dr.
Hoda's will be meeting and interacting
with many of our faculty and trainees
and several different forums including a
scientific poster session please join me
in welcoming dr. Hodes back to Yale
well thank you very much for the chance
to come back home it really is a great
privilege to be here and a pleasure to
be following congresswoman DeLauro you
know she was talking about times past
which evoke I think a healthy kind of
nostalgia you can perhaps imagine from
her descriptions the times not so many
years ago when Republicans Democrats
bipartisan members of Congress and
appropriations committee would dedicate
day after day to have come before them
the directors of each of the NIH 27
institutes and centers a chance to talk
about the work that all of you were
doing to have it appreciated to
communicate to our policymakers the
importance of what was happening and as
she's noted we don't have those
opportunities so much anymore but we can
all hope that they will come when we can
once more return to to that style of
communication with our national leaders
it's a great pleasure to be here and to
introduce or open this symposium the
title is rather pretentious I hope I
didn't really make it up but what is
striking is you'll see in a brief
summary i'll give you of the way in
which research is supported across niña
the Institute on Aging and some of the
major areas of research you'll see how
closely it maps really to the
presentations you'll be hearing I'm sure
just a coincidence because it does
reflect as noted the leadership in each
of these major areas of science that you
here at Yale have have played so let me
talk about the major divisions of
research support at niña the first in
the division of aging biology as you can
see reflected in the name this is the
area of discipline that looked to
understand what the underlying molecular
cellular genetic basis is for aging as
will turn to as a theme i think that
crosses much of what we're doing with
recognition that what is important for
aging really underlies issues of health
across organs tissues and lifespan so
there's a centers program which provides
infrastructure and then a series of
programs and like of cell biology
genetics immunology want to go on
through all of the areas of basic
science you know so well in terms of a
suggestion of the future and
opportunities in this area I would just
highlight what was a very recent event
last week held in Bethesda
and it was sponsored by a gyro science
interest group neuroscience is a
relatively recent term I think coined
about 2007 give credit to the folks at
the buck Institute in California and it
reflects the fact that there is likely
underlying relevance for the aging
process to many of the conditions that
accompany aging him so by understanding
the biology of aging we in fact served
not just anti-aids mission but that
across all of NIH all those interested
in health and well-being this interest
group presented a summit that was opened
by Francis Collins then had a series of
keynote presentations that really
spanned demographics health issues and
underlying biology you can see the
session titles here doctoral Dixit was
one of the participants there at
inflammation but inflammation stress
epigenetics all these major areas
underlying biology have been apart now
of a gyro sites interest group at NIH
which is now 20 NIH Institute's strong
and the commitment of Institute centers
and directors to these missions so our
hope is at a time when the budget is
clearly constrained when niña and each
Institute has a great challenge in
funding the outstanding research
opportunities in each field that we can
increase the commitment and conviction
that research relevant aging is indeed
relevant to all institutes and centers
and you'll be hearing some of this today
so if sandy talks about telomeres and
their relationship to biology the
connection the cancer will be there and
so this theme goes I think across areas
of basic biology of aging the division
of geriatric vertical gerontology is the
division that sponsors the more clinical
aspects of aging research and the pepper
centers the older Americans independent
centers such as that here are part of
the purview of this division it has
interest in some areas that are quite
germane to aging as a process such as
menopause some conditions that you'll be
hearing about such as frailty or or
increasing risks of comorbidities that
are accompanying aging but it really
crosses as you will see here many
aspects of diseased condition over an
age span and if there is a theme that i
think is becoming more and more dominant
in this area and this is not just a
table across NIH
it's one which dr. tinetti has certainly
pioneered and emphasizing that our focus
for understandable reasons on individual
conditions or diseases in isolation is
important but it's failing if it doesn't
account for the fact that multiple
morbidities the existence of multiple
conditions concurrently need to be
addressed this is clearly a theme across
NIH across other federal agencies and
Medicare Medicaid and you'll be hearing
some about that today too certainly if
we're picking one major thrust of the
programs it's going to be supported by
NIH and years to come this is at the
very top of the list I want to know one
interesting opportunity that's emerged
at a time when the funding is quite
limited the NIH budget is not going up
in fact it's been decreasing of late
we're starting looking for opportunities
to collaborate in one agency one
organization that appeared in the last
two years is pecora the patient-centered
outcomes Research Institute many of you
may be aware of it it's a
non-governmental agency it's funded by a
tax if you will on on on healthcare
premiums and it has a budget that is
increasing year by year and looking for
opportunities to invest in the kind of
research that will be of interest
patient-centered outcomes being the key
to what is being pursued and happy to
announce the very first occasion of an
investment of funds by pocari in an NIH
supported clinical research study in
this case clinical trial will be in the
trial was announced some time ago now
with applications in being reviewed
committing up to 30 million dollars in
support of interventions in partnership
with NIH to prevent Falls and injuries
associated with Falls an older Americans
so I think a sense of one of the top
themes the first where we hopefully many
such collaborations and folks in an area
that's been close to aging research and
certainly close to the work here at Yale
and at the pepper center the division of
behavior and social research is a third
of our for extramural divisions that
spans a wide spectrum of research from
individual sciences such as psychology
through the population sciences such as
demography and economics it has
maintained a number of centers programs
as well as studies that have for the
first time
characterized at a high level of
specificity the longitudinal
consequences of aging over time terms of
health biology but also behavior
finances and social issues one thing
which again I think will be related very
much what you'll be hearing today from
from from the presentation that talks
about the evolutionary conservation of
social interactions is the general theme
reflected here in the rubric we call
reversibility of early disadvantage and
the reason there's a nonhuman primate
monkeys in the picture here in a
division of behavior and social research
reflects an increased understanding of
the way in which behaviors are connected
to physical and biological properties be
an epigenetic changes in DNA that
reflect the outcomes of experience and
exposure but issues that are common to
all organisms through evolution and
reversibility here reflects to the fact
that early life experience sometimes
adverse produces consequences which if
not interfered with themselves can be
quite negative they can now in very
exciting areas of research be understood
in terms of both behavior but also the
underlying or associated biology and
epigenetics and the ability to reverse
such changes holding great promise to
try to devise interventions being a
behavioral or biological to address and
reverse outcomes of particular adverse
events that may have occurred earlier in
life and life span the division of
neuroscience a major in fact the largest
of the four divisions reflects the fact
that niña is the lead agency for
research and alzheimer disease although
it's more than Alzheimer's disease
that's being studied it's changes that
occur over time with age in cognitive
function but also in other sensory motor
functions and functions such as sleep
and here I just want to outline for you
some of the changes that have occurred
in the past couple of years as a result
of a national effort that has focused
resources attention on Alzheimer's
disease in particular the research has
included a dramatic increase in
understanding genetic contributions to
Alzheimer's disease we used to show one
by one the genes that had been
associated as risk or protective factors
for Alzheimer's and now I think we can
much more productively show what is I
think the future of such research not
just individual genes and names which
may not mean much to most of us or you
but the way in which these risk factors
the genes that affect Alzheimer's risk
fall into categories the one you see
first here were the greatest list of
genes below it innate immune response
brain inflammatory response reflects a
likelihood that would so many genes that
affect the risk of Alzheimer's disease
being related to inflammation that it
may be that pathways of inflammation
affecting the brain are those targets
where we will perhaps have earliest
opportunity to intervene and have income
and similarly across lipid transport
synaptic transmission cytoskeletal we're
learning more and more about the way in
which risk factors fall into patterns
that suggest underlying processes which
we hope identify targets that can be
validated than used for intervention the
National Alzheimer's project act was an
act which was passed by both houses of
Congress and signed by the president not
so common occurrence these days but
which established a national plan to
address Alzheimer's disease one
important component of that was research
the areas of research were translated
into priorities and a plan that it has
milestones all targeted to produce the
effective interventions by 2025 a stated
goal and science it's hard to promise
and we make it clear that we're not
promising and there we don't know what
of course will be but nonetheless a goal
which motivates all of us with budgets
as restricted as they are this is one
area in which NIH director with
difficult choices to be made was able to
make additional funds available in 2012
and 2013 to carry out some incremental
studies that would not otherwise have
been done with available budgets and I
just want to stress to you the kinds of
research the excitement in it that are
being carried out by some examples here
one is an approach to identify novel
targets and Alzheimer's you know we're
very effective at following areas of
research that are promising and are
undoubtedly important but perhaps the
greatest challenge is to force ourselves
motivate ourselves to look at areas that
are not what is most apparent and so
this isn't a
an initiative that really asked
investigators to respond with strategies
for identifying new potential targets
now some disease that were not the
conventional ones and the pattern of
mostly studies is really in the opening
of a very new and I think phenomenally
interesting area of science based on on
network and systems analyses
mathematical analyses of large data sets
that really has been possible only in
the last couple of years that have
compared for example gene expression
patterns or protein expression patterns
or gene sequences in hundreds of people
who either have Alzheimer's disease or
don't or where tissues expressed in
various areas of the brain will have
different such patterns and from all of
that to deduce the targets that none of
the nodes for what appear to be the most
important pathways in disease and I
think this is an example of basic
science investigated that is going to
open new opportunities in this area
couple with the effort to increase our
basic discovery science base have been
some areas to translate what we already
know as promising opportunities into
clinical trials to prevent Alzheimer's
disease now sad to say we've all been
highly disappointed with the fact that
the large clinical trials addressing
Alzheimer disease in the years through
the president have been extremely
disappointing if not yet had great
success I think there's a conviction
well based that a lot is may relate to
the fact that these studies were carried
out generally in individuals who had
advanced state of changes in the brain
manifest by disease a time at which
substantial damage has been done
probably very difficult to reverse so
you'll see in the pattern of these
studies that are being supported now an
attempt to look earlier and earlier in
the underlying course the disease before
symptoms even appear and techniques such
as brain imaging have been enormously
accessed successful in finding changes
that in fact predict disease years or
even decades before hands who are now
able for the first time to address
interventions at this early stage before
largely irreparable damage may have been
done with we hope greater promise of
success and so examples of some of the
studies that are being carried out here
the Alzheimer's prevention initiative
taking individuals who have the apoe4
allele a strong risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease but who
have not yet developed any symptoms and
beginning early to address therapy in
this case therapies that target beta
amyloid to see if it's possible to
prevent the advanced clinical stage of
disease similarly I mentioned the
growing body of evidence that
inflammation the immune system may be
playing a role in the etiology of
Alzheimer's so stimulating an innate
immune system in fact in this case with
gm-csf a hormone growth factor to see if
it's possible to head off the early
stages of advanced there and similarly
the dominant inherited Alzheimer's
Network trial just to point out there
are tragic families with Alzheimer's
disease determined by specific genetic
mutations where Alzheimer's develops in
the 50s 40s even 30s enormous tragedies
but with a lot to teach us about the
underlying biology and with individuals
who are desperate themselves for
intervention so the trial such as this
will actually begin to treat people 10
or 15 years before we know with
certainty those individuals will develop
Alzheimer's disease if not treated
examples of opportunities that are
arising these last years and give us a
new hope for in fact making a difference
in this very terrible disease and let me
just end with the slide illustrating
that the brain initiative this is one
that was announced with a great deal of
fanfare by the White House that sets the
enormously ambitious goal of over the
next decade or so trying to understand
that the level of individual neurons in
the brain not only what each of them is
doing but how they connect with one
another audacious is the word applied I
think but it's likely to drive a new
generation of neuroscience in advance
that we hope will take us to areas of
not just understanding of underlying
biology but an opportunity to see the
targets by which we can increase the
success successful aging in the context
of the session of hearing about today in
the brain in the rest of the body in the
mind and the quality of life and it's
improvement so that as we continue our
success in extending life span as you've
heard expressed already we can manage to
make that life span of the highest
possible quality of Independence and
good health
so I leave the you with this as just an
expression of the breadth of research
and aging that we think holds great
promise you'll see without coincidence
this is really typical of the
cutting-edge work being done across the
programs here at Yale and I look forward
with you to sharing the experience of
hearing from the very talented leaders
in the field who will be talking over
these next hours and thank you again for
the opportunity to be back here